[音楽]
買っちまったよこちらに見えるダンボールを待って多くね多く持った深いてわかると
思いますけどこちらをご覧ください
ボールプール用のクールでございますボールですねボールプール用のボールでござい
ますボールプールってあの子供の時に入った事ある方多いと思うんですけどもフールの
形のところに神楽たくさんってそこで行
ああああああ
って遊べやつなんですけれどもそれを初12万円分館でしまいました
やべたいという夢から何をしようかといいますと
認知度上にいきましょうはい業者さんに頼んでこの部屋をボールプールでコーヒー男児
プーにするときにゴルフれてなく入りますかアンテナ
聞いてみたら82前かかりましたやっぱいんだよじゃないけど俺はこの星になって
ボール風に入ってみたくなった
ガーお店
ファーボールプールだと年愛制限12歳以下やら身長何センチか色々あって
こんな大きな僕はもう帰れないとなるとボールプロファイルって自分で作るしかないと
いうことで今日は女か誰でもよろしくです最高のボールプールを作っていこうと思い
ますではいがー
よっちゃに僕は値段はしているがボールの母さまだ知っていない道路とかじゃねこれ
ん
約5万個になります
それが多いのは少ないかもわからないでトレード運んでみます5万個でしょ
想像つかないじゃん1個目入れ土でブレジナ入ってるかなのかすごい気になりますね
saas 5 a めっちゃ綺麗じゃあ
どんどんやりますああああああああ
もうあ抜けませ編誤解なんだけどもはできないですね
はぁ
もう結構やばいんだねーあああただしの電話がないよね委員会ボールを多くの方にやり
ましょう
ああああああ
はっはっは
dee
生地が終わったので
またたーーー
測りはさあ
パワーすいません汗が止まらないとちょっと一時的にシャトーにはそれはねもう
ビッショビショすぎてやばいますでっ
けどこれ
[音楽]
ああああああ
ran ん
[音楽]
ます
やばいカメラのバック留学しましたこの中でどうなっ
それじゃないぞ活用はてどうすればいいのこれない
[音楽]
teame
2バッハ
あっああん
[音楽]
ええええええ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
パッハーツたっ
プーパパスポパパパぱわー
うわぁを燃えろ俺やばいパスポットにうまいわー
ええええええ
はいこういうわけで不意に完成しました僕が今年
ナイトプールに入っていません
でも大寂しくないあっはぁはぁっ
dare
[拍手]
me
tee
さあサーファー
ああああああ
ああああああああ
rar
ああああーー
込んだ
宮部
26歳になっても楽しいいやこれ多分
なぜきもちいいですよ高さ1m ぐらいを隠されてて僕の方なんてことは僕の新著
くらいの波がありますからね
池浦消化
[拍手]
いやこれちょっと待っやばやばいまあこれ
著なかなかやばいこれ移動がねほんとプールなんですけども僕はできました
相当深いプールになっておりますこれは膨らもう
ね早はこれたして作ることによって気がするんだよ
はぁ
アヴェダ食べるのがこれ飛び込んでも怪我しないよねた滑り込んだけど大丈夫だと思い
ます
じゃあ
[音楽]
痛くないああああああ
me
ん
dare you do
どうしようああ
me
teame
ana あああっ